hello and welcome to martial matters
with me Winston Marshall at The
Spectator buildings in London today I'm
joined by comedy Legend
multi-bafter winning
creator of Father Ted Black Books The IT
Crowd and writer for brassai the
day-to-day the far show Graham linahan
Graham thank you so much for taking the
time to speak with me today thank you
thank you for asking me uh so I watched
these shows growing up this is very
special for me and but what I just
learned is that actually you started in
music yeah how did you get from music to
Comedy uh well I was a music journalist
in a magazine called hot press in Dublin
and Arthur Matthews who went on to write
Ted with me was the uh art layout guy
um and this was a time when magazines
the way they printed the magazine was
like if you made a mistake you had to
cut out the word and post it over the
copy
um and then photocopier or something and
send it off so this was pre-computers so
the the last weekend before publication
was grindingly slow and boring and
Arthur and a man named Paul woodfall who
we nicknamed Paul wonderful uh used to
kind of carry on a comedy routine
between between themselves
um
that would just have us all in stitches
and I really kind of fell in love with
with with with with Arthur especially uh
what was the routine well they had a few
one of the things they did was uh they
did a they pretended to be
um inner city Dublin Taekwondo
instructors
and they they had a joke that went
Taekwondo uh comes from two words uh two
Korean words te meaning head or
intellect and quando meaning to butter
you know and uh they had like they had
stuff like this
um and also uh Paul was in a band called
The Joshua Trio that Arthur drummed for
and every so often Arthur would when
Paul was doing a costume change I think
it was Arthur would come out from behind
a drunk hit and put a dog collar in and
he would do this character called Father
Ted
you know one of one of our favorite
jokes he did was he said uh if there's
anyone at the back who can't see say
hello to them they're from Saint Kevin's
School for the Blind
so there were all these kind of um so
you know it was it was not just like
like funny it was like sophisticated and
funny it was it was really strong stuff
and um
I was noticing that on TV the stuff
wasn't as strong I thought that that's a
joke these jokes aren't these jokes are
better crafted than what we're seeing on
TV so you know for me it was it was not
that much of a jump to ask him to come
to London
um which I did when select magazine
which was the big Brit pot magazine I
think you could say uh brought me over
to write for them and I said to Arthur
will you will you come over and join us
and we'll give it a go so he came over
and you created Father Ted the TV show
yeah although we we kind of um like he
thought he'd be over for a few months he
ended up staying 10 years and uh like
you know we started off writing sketches
and handing them into radio shows
because we were told that radio was was
the way in but then one day we were
looking at Smith and Jones uh Griffeys
Johns and Mel Smith show
and there was a list of writers at the
end and it went out for ages and I
realized oh my God they probably take
submissions so he sent in a few sketches
to them and uh got called in for a
meeting almost immediately so ever since
then it's been you know Griff got us our
agent
um you know we we were able to hand
scripts directly and or ideas for
sitcoms directly into TalkBack and then
to hat-trick
and it just took off from there really
you know we
you know we were learning as we went we
didn't know how to write a sitcom but uh
our first in fact our first sitcom was a
disaster because uh
we we we would write them to be 40
minutes long
um and and we wouldn't cut it down
because we were you know we were kind of
digging our heels in and thinking that
oh they're trying to they're trying to
take out our jokes but then of course
when it got into the edit we had to cut
it down to 29 minutes you know I
remember once I I think I think I asked
someone can we ask Channel 4 just not to
run ads
you know so um
that was a real lesson in in humility
and and um
you know and and something I've I've
borne in mind ever since which is that
the people who are giving you notes
aren't trying to ruin your show they're
trying to help you so uh when Father Ted
came along we had a great producer in
Jeffrey Perkins who had a very light
touch but would would steer us towards
telling stronger stories getting funnier
moments at what we had he had a great
phrase he used to say I think you're
missing a trick here and and I loved
hearing that because it meant that we
were about to discover a whole new area
of Comedy that we didn't realize was
there
um he sadly died recently and uh you
know like you know relatively recently
wonderful mom also produced The
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy true
English gentleman lowly blog
um and um yeah so so you know through
through tutorship from from someone like
Jeffrey and and some other brilliant
producers we worked with like Sean at
William and and Lisa Evans
um we we just learned learned on the job
you know so uh yeah and uh you've also I
didn't mention this earlier uh now uh
have a new side of your uh life which is
that your women's rights activist and
that has clashed with your work on
Father Ted where you your father Ted
musical was axed apparently because of
your controversial opinions what was the
story with the musical well my my
like controversial opinions are not
actually very controversial they're
they're shared by the vast majority of
people in this country
um that you shouldn't give kids uh uh
surgical interventions and
pharmaceutical interventions that might
have long lasting effects that women
don't deserve to lose their livelihoods
for being feminists that JK Rowling
doesn't deserve to have death and rate
threats sent to her
um that male prisoners shouldn't be
placed in the female estate that NHS
Wards should be women only
like these are not controversial
opinions but
um unfortunately we have a kind of a
middle class that that is captured by
all these you know absurd ideas
um
and uh you know it the the kind of False
Consensus they've created around these
issues uh comes about true intimidation
and Force and and canceling and so on so
uh so I knew that if I started talking
about this I noticed that
women online were were beginning to be
um vilified and and harassed out of
their jobs and and all this so I I I
realized that if I started speaking
about it more clearly and explicitly I'd
be in trouble so
um I had a spot of cancer a few years
ago uh that was that was easily taken
care of
um but I got a nice insurance payout
from it so I said to my wife
you know we're gonna I'm gonna to start
talking about this and they're gonna
come after my livelihood so we can use
this money to to to keep going until the
Ted musical happens because they tell it
that Ted musical would be too big to
cancel so to speak
um
and uh unfortunately then covet came
along and extended the the uh extended
the time we were waiting to get it done
and during that time I was banned from
Twitter for saying men aren't women and
men aren't women though is the exact
tweets men aren't women though and um
and you know the the the the narrative
around me began to
consistently say that I was anti-trans
that I was you know in fact that's what
my Wikipedia entry says and if ever I
tried to change it changes backward in
15 minutes so there was a kind of a you
know
because because up until that point I
was the biggest
um account on Twitter talking about this
issue it was before JK Rowling came came
into the uh onto the scene
um I was a big Target you know so you
knew going into it that this would be
the case you said just now yeah you told
your wife I'm going to get a lot of
pushback through this for these opinions
uh so do you have any regrets about
going into it and and did you if you
knew you had pushback did you know to
what extent it would happen that's the
only thing that's the only regret I have
I didn't know they would come after my
wife I didn't know they would release
her address online
and I didn't know they would uh that
people would privately get in touch with
her and tell her to tell me to stop
talking she came under a lot of pressure
um if I if I thought about it a bit
longer I would have taken steps to
protect her more but um but you know I
was eager to get into the into the fight
because I was seeing what mermaids were
doing to young children and the
Tavistock uh which is the gender
identity Clinic uh that's that's uh
being closed down soon
um and uh I thought this is too much of
an emergency to to rest on our Laurels
we have to fight it straight away you
know I saw people like Kathleen stock
getting bullied uh by a Forester losing
her job and I just thought
it would be immoral to ignore all these
things yeah you know uh where do where
do you think that the passion to stand
up against this Injustice as you've
noticed it came from well I've always uh
I was bullied at school you know I was
very tall so I would um try and Shrink
damn it's where I've got my I've got a
bit of a stoop and uh I I would try and
hide and and and my parents had this
thing where they basically told me never
to hit back you know
um they were very my my mom was this you
know like a lot of moms in the world
terrified of anything happening to me so
so I I would hold back I was I was very
you know I I would hold back when I when
I was being subjected to things and I
think the kind of anger grew in me then
at any kind of bullying and I especially
don't like bullying against women
because like as a friend of mine says
Debbie Hayden
um you know the bullies she describes
trans rights activists as the bullies
even the other bullies hated at school
the bullies are bully girls and that's
what they are they are
despicable carrots who pick on women so
I
thought yeah I mean you know I just I
just it's just my number one
um I just hate bullies yeah so Father
Ted the musical yeah
what what happened there they were you
you you're about to the show covid
happened and then they closed it down
and said no it's not going to happen
yeah we we did two we we got it on its
feet partially uh twice uh we did a read
through with the songs or I think we did
a read through maybe without the songs
or or with just uh very simplified
versions of the songs and then we did
another read through where we
choreographed how the songs might look
and so on and played that to some of the
people involved
um and they both went great the the the
show feels ready to go uh perhaps a
little bit of rewriting is needed but
not much
um and yeah but but unfortunately all
throughout all this period I kept
getting intimate and um
uh demands to stop talking about the
issue but again we're talking about
we're talking about the health of
children demands from who the producers
my colleagues one of my colleagues
actually
rang my wife and put pressure on her to
tell her to stop
um
you know it it's that's a surely that's
a line that unacceptable to cross the
the person involved which I was thinking
of naming them but the person involved
still hasn't hasn't apologized you know
he put pressure on my marriage when we
were under a huge amount of pressure
already because trans rights activists
had targeted my life and myself and
we're doing everything they could to
um
to keep me quiet
so uh for for him to join in that is is
pretty pretty low I think
um but uh yeah so this happened and
eventually I I was so frustrated by all
this I've actually I've actually queued
up the letter I wrote to I wrote this
letter to hatrick who were the producers
of Father Ted and Sonya frieden Jimmy
Moville is hat trick and Sonya Friedman
of Sonia Friedman Productions is like
one of the biggest producers in the West
End and Arthur and Neil Hannon as well
and I said basically um
I'm living under a bit of a cloud when I
don't think you all have my back as
collaborators or as business partners or
as friends far from being on the wrong
side of History JK Rowling and I have
been proved right over and over again
this is a poisonous ideology that is
destroying lives and both sides are not
to blame for the toxicity
I said Sonia you know how Jake is
sukastania is a friend of JK Rowling's
said Sonia you know how JK Rowling has
suffered and how her heart must break
every day
and then finish by saying stop telling
me to stop standing up for her and my
daughter my daughter is not a cervix
hover she is a woman and she is my
daughter don't anyone dare use Ted as
leverage to make me abandon my daughter
or I will simply take it elsewhere that
might have been a little strong I I
guess so at the end I basically just
said I said I'm sorry to have to put it
in such strong terms but these people
are monsters and everyone needs to start
standing up to them I can't force you to
be brave but I can ask you to stop
adding to the pressure that is currently
on me I will not abandon my daughter
um and then I got a call from Jimmy
mobile saying come to come to London for
a meeting and at the late meeting he
told me to he told me they didn't want
me involved with the musical wow and
they offered me 200 000 pounds to walk
away from it I mean when you talk about
your daughter like that earlier in the
conversation you say it's your you want
to stand up to bullies but also the love
of a father for his daughter to protect
to protect his daughter that surely
would resonate with with everyone it's
such a strange I I just don't understand
it like I remember I said to Jimmy Mogul
what have I said that you disagree with
and he rolled his eyes I still don't
know I still don't know what they
disagree with yeah you know and and I
just don't understand how and there are
other colleagues on the show who have
wives and who have daughters and I just
don't understand how they can't be
fighting this stuff this is the most
pernicious anti-female
misogynistic movement I've ever seen
well I look back at your career and
activism you were in Ireland uh you were
fighting for to repeal the eighth so I
approached voice position which came
into law in 2018 and it seems to me from
a progressive point of view there is a
consistency in you standing for women
then
and then again now standing for women in
the trans debate why do you think it is
that so many
are the progressors perhaps most other
progressives have taken a different
course against women and children and
for Trans rights well
I I would I would edit that slightly
simply by saying that that it's not so
much against trans right it's against a
version of trans rights that is directly
opposed women's rights the the the you
know I I'm friend one of the ironies of
this whole thing is that I'm friends
with more trans people than the people
calling me transphobic and they are
um uh you know distraught at what's been
happening supposedly in their name you
know uh Debbie Hayden is a good example
Miranda Yardley is another one
um they they both find this
um as insane as as as as I do but their
voices are ignored because this is an
ideological battle it's not an ethical
battle this is a battle of ideas and if
you have the wrong idea at the time at
this particular time
I don't know I mean I guess you can call
it Council culture although that
sometimes seems like uh not quite the
right phrase but but everyone is
frightened everyone uh would rather go
away which is why they offered me so
much money to go away from Ted
um did you take the money no I
considered it for a while and I even
started working on a statement with
Jimmy Moville
um
you know that that protected me and and
and and and made things not seem so
I don't know
like I was being punished for something
but then uh one day I was listening to a
an interview with a teammate of Leah
Thomas Leah Thomas is the hulking man
who is cheating at Women's swimming uh
and was on a team with these with these
young women and the mother of one of the
teammates
was on uh it was being interviewed
and she burst into tears because her she
was recounting her her daughter said I
don't know what I can do when if he
comes in when I'm changing and this
mother said I I was crying because it or
no no she said I'm crying because it's
it's 20 22 and I have to tell my
daughter that she has every right to
tell to privacy and and she literally
doesn't know she has that right and and
this woman was in tears and I just
thought I I'm I'm not going to agree to
any anything this is this is monstrous
what's happening to women
so I I said no I'm not going to do it
I'm not going to take the money you know
and I I genuinely thought they'd go okay
we were a bit silly let's let's get get
it back on the road you know because the
show is so good and so perfect and so
nearly there and but no no apparently uh
they'll only make the show if I die or
something
they didn't actually say that no do you
know what I mean what else are they
waiting for
um what can you take us into the world
of of production comedy are these people
do they really are they scared of the
controversy that they'll get in the
press or do they believe the ideology do
they believe you're wrong or do they you
know Jimmy where do they stand on it do
you think we have to speculate but if we
can speculate I can I can I think I know
what's happening I mean I spoke to Jimmy
a few times Jimmy both Jimmy and Sonia
uh shared what have become thought
terminating cliches that are fed to
people so that they say the correct
thing Jimmy said there's bad behavior on
both sides of the argument which is not
true I asked him to name some bad bad
behavior from our side and he couldn't
um and Sonia Friedman said I was on the
wrong side of History
yeah so these are just these are just
cliches trotted out by trans rice
activists because they don't have any
any arguments they don't actually have
any arguments or that they perhaps not
really looked into it yeah very much
they don't particularly care about the
issue in a yeah exactly I mean you know
the the the JK Rowling being a bigot is
accepted by like millions of people and
yet there's not a shred of evidence of
this bigotry yeah so it's basically just
fear of
fear of young people fear of the young
people in their companies fear of their
own kids who I think have have them held
hostage a lot of the time with these
opinions
um as what do you mean by that I think I
think I think kids are telling their
parents the uh the the usual kind of you
know things like the debunked suicide
statistics uh the debunk statistics
about
um about uh the the uh safety of puberty
blockers none of these things stand up
but but the but the lines of arguments
are very very they endure no matter what
again JK Rowling you know the fact that
she's toxic it's enduring despite all
evidence yeah you know what I mean so
they're just they're just kind of um
in this middle class bubble of of of of
of people who who believe this
fashionable evil ideology I think if you
just I think support your argument that
against the the the the idea that there
are bad people on both sides if you look
at the debate and who's actually
suffering consequences for their
opinions and I've had a lot of these
guests on the show as I've already
mentioned James Dreyfus and we've talked
about JK Rowling who people say oh she's
not canceled she can still speak well
actually she's still having professional
repercussions for her opinions not to
mention the bigotry and the death threat
she's endlessly receiving uh but also on
the show I've had Rosie K who had to
force to resign from her dance company
for having gender critical opinions uh
I've uh on a separate event spoken to
Jester Wells who in art was forced to
thinks the Royal Academy where she was
uh had her work taken down and uh
fortunately reinstated and in music and
work when she I come from Craig Potter
of how elbow was wiped from social media
from being supportive of children and
worrying about I think it was mermaids
Christian Henson as well at Spitfire
music he founded spitfat co-founded
Spitfire music and has was forced to be
he was suspended from that so it seems
to me that it's the gender critical
people who are standing up for women's
rights who are being punished for their
opinions and on the other side I don't
see the punishment as much no there's no
punishment and there's no but and you
know but the punishment makes you think
there must have been a crime but there
has been no crime like you know and and
also the other thing about Council
culture is that it's not just artists
that are being affected there's a social
social worker who's now being who's
being subjected to her name is Rachel
Mead being subjected to endless
investigations because she shared one of
my blogs the guy from Spitfire actually
was was was in trouble for sharing
something I said
um uh you know there's there's PL I've
done police film women who were fired
from a police a a detective who was
fired from her job
um uh you know
I know a woman who
um lost her chance to be a foster carer
because she wouldn't she said she
wouldn't transition a child you know
um it's it's affecting people at every
level of society yeah
um so it's not like a kind of that's the
thing about when people say cancel
culture they immediately think of people
like Rowley and people like myself but
it's affecting everyone yeah and it's
affecting Ordinary People worst of all
because
you know I mean like like like uh Rachel
Mead she's not a billionaire so she she
can't fight with as much Gusto and and
and bravery as as Rowling
um she's much more exposed and much more
vulnerable to as I say this this
ideology that's just kind of swept
through the middle class like a like a
forest fire you know well if we could
stick to Comedy just for a little bit
more because uh another
noticeable uh cancellation was the scene
from the I.T crowd uh that was removed
from channel four in 2020 where one of
the characters falls in love with a
trans woman if that's correct it was
actually a whole episode the whole
episode the whole episode offline yeah
okay so what happened there they just
wrote to me and they said they they
wrote a letter that was full of
Stonewall talking points none of which
are true the idea that trans people are
under some sort of violent Threat all
the time it's a lie it's based on
nothing it's actually based on the
murder rates of Brazilian
trans-identified prostitutes where it's
not the fact that they're trans that's
leading to these murders it's the fact
that they're sex workers so um you know
the the they they fed me this line of
[ __ ] and said that's why we're
taking it off I'm sure you understand
and they offered me the use for PR to to
kind of uh limit the damage you know but
I just I said I said I I told him to
[ __ ] off you know because it's
outrageous outrageous they think the
scene itself was offensive yeah they
were saying it was promoting violence
against trans people but it's just it's
just a kind of it's an action-packed
parody of Matrix films with the two of
them fighting
Matt Berry and and
um uh oh my goodness that's terrible
forgotten her name it's their names
jumped out of my head but the actress
who played uh who played uh the trans
character you know it it it's basically
even if there had been no fight the
episode would have still been banned
because what they don't like is is humor
they hate humor they hate anyone any
thought of anyone making a joke about
anything to do with trans because trans
like the priesthood in Ireland
Trends in the UK at the moment is a
sacred class you know trans people are
sacred class and you're not allowed to
make fun of them you're not allowed to
criticize you're not allowed to do
anything and uh because I I wrote an
episode where I just didn't observe any
of these absurd taboos they had to they
had to get rid of it you know
um so despite what might appear like a
very pessimistic time from our
conversation so far I would say that
2022 has you've indicated on many fronts
and you could see it pretty positively
uh the Tavistock Clinic uh which is the
NHS run gender Clinic offering sex
change surgery and puberty blockers for
children at the expense of the British
taxpayer he's been told to close by
Spring next year uh Elon Musk is
offering a Twitter amnesty it was
supposed to be this week you haven't yet
been reinstated but there's a good
chance that you will be reins stated and
just moments ago we learned that the
charity commission are having a
statutory inquiry into mermaids we these
are all things well certainly to have a
stalk of mermaids as well as other
issues things that you've been calling
out for years now do you feel Vindicated
yeah but you know I always felt
Vindicated in the sense that like I knew
I knew we were right I knew we were
right I mean I mean when you think about
it a a a a a a part of the NHS that
gives sex change operations to children
like how did we even
how did anyone come to think that that
was in any on any level acceptable you
know so vindication
it's not as sweet as it should be for me
because there was never any doubt in my
mind that I'd be Vindicated you know
it's just like um uh it's it's I'm just
waiting for people to catch up and
unfortunately even with all these
advances women are still losing their
livelihoods this ideology has kind of
permeated into institutions all over the
UK uh disastrously most of all uh
education I think
um what surges ask us about education
because it's it's it's it's it's it's uh
it's it's in incubating or inculcating
I'm not sure what the word is uh these
these ideas into the Next Generation and
uh it is a form of grooming it's for it
is a form of grooming it's form of
ideological grooming
um and children have much less of a
defense against it uh than we grown-ups
do uh we're being controlled by
fear and uh and and intimidation but
kids kids will believe anything you tell
them what do you think needs to be done
in Education to fix that uh the activist
teachers have to be rooted out activist
teachers are a real problem
um and also you know it just has to be
it has to be one one thing that that
really can be done parents need to make
sure that they're talking to their
schools and saying I hope you're not
telling our kids that they can be born
in the wrong body or that some men or
women or whatever you know so I think
you know again with more awareness with
with the mermaid story breaking you know
becoming a bigger Scandal every day
um I I think that there's a chance we
can fight back against it but you know
when you see NHS documents calling women
cervix habits or when you see NHS
documents saying that our sex is
assigned at Birth by
um you know a a Doctor Who's bored
that's a real problem and I I wonder how
long it's going to take to to extricate
it from society really what's your take
on on mermaids do you do you think that
they're salvageable as as a a charity or
or do you think that they're too far
gone and I think the brand is is dead uh
unfortunate which is and actually an
unfortunate thing because before Susie
Green mermaids was halfway seen what's
Susie Green's role Susie Green was the
CEO who recently resigned but before
Susie Green uh mermaids had a Splat had
a landing page on their website that
said that most kids who who have
dysphoria will grow up to be gay most
kids grow out of it
um on surgical intervention is is to be
seen as a last resort so they were you
know we would all agree with these are
these are the turf positions if you will
so these these positions are we're
completely saying but then Susie grain
came along Susie Green is someone who
like prepped completely openly on her
Ted Talk spoke about how when her when
her child was still a toddler her son
was still a toddler her husband didn't
like the fact that he played with girls
toys
and completely openly in this Ted talk
without any further explanation
she starts describing how the kid was
put on hormones and then castrated in
Thailand at 16. her 16th birthday she
brought him to Thailand and castrated
because she had convinced him groomed
into thinking that he was actually a
girl this is a young gay kid a young kid
who would have grown up to be gay that's
my that's what I believe she did and I
think that what happened with mermaids
is mermaids then became an organization
that acted as a kind of after the fact
uh defense of what she did to her child
so it's it's mermaids is an organization
that has been poisoned by one person
then two in the like later on Helen
weberly came along the doc the another
one of these disgraceful doctors who's
prescribing these drugs to kids
and a lot of parents who uh some of whom
I I believe will will probably end up
being homophobic you know some of whom
are just confused and think they're
doing the right thing and think that
mermaids are the experts
um but the whole thing was just kind of
did the whole organization was was
transformed by Susie gray and uh she's
like she has no expertise in this at all
she's an I.T consultant so
I don't it's like the the inquired they
won't survive the inquiry and I don't
think that the brand Will Survive the
inquiry either yeah at a recent Battle
of ideas dinner
you made a speech which people can read
on your sub stack and you ask the
question how has this ideology achieved
so much so quickly well uh
basically what you found with the
internet was a way that
people could Escape their their
individual uh Echo Chambers and speak to
others so you had a number of different
Echo Chambers online you had young kids
who were self-diagnosing on Tumblr
you had
academics who uh were forming what you
might call it a false body of knowledge
in post-modern uh thought and queer
Theory
um you had Predators who were looking
for victims
and you had grifters who were sensing an
opportunity and all these people online
they formed a giant bubble that also
unfortunately brought in people from the
media publishing uh theater uh you know
uh even therapy and
they formed a False Consensus based on
as I say these kind of repeated thought
terminating cliches like wrong side of
History
um
but also uh
intimidation and threats of cancellation
if you if you disagreed with any of it
so you know the Twitter just enabled uh
the pylons and it enabled the bullying
and it enabled the the concerted letter
writing campaigns and and all this type
of thing actually I have a theory that
another another reason
we are where we are is because of spell
check
because uh now lunatics you you can't
really tell their lunatics because
they've run their letters through spell
check
s
because of course before we could tell
you before you go this guy you don't
need to take him seriously but now
everything is impeccably spelled
yeah you know so I think in many ways
spell check has brought about you know
the end of the western world
oh
but you know
it's dorm of of
stupidity and cowardice and group think
and all these things and it would not
have been possible I think without the
internet you know when does this end for
you when are you going to be able to get
back to Comedy
well let me put it this way the next I
have I've already written my next show
and it's the Father Ted Musical and I'm
not really interested in doing anything
until that's produced so uh I'm gonna
keep talking about it I'm gonna keep
fighting for it and another thing that
that I'm that I'm that I'm I definitely
want to do is if if like like the Father
Ted musical was more than just
um a show that
I felt could be written because I never
wanted to waste people's time with like
excuse me to them But the Sex Pistols
reunion you know there would be nothing
sadder than that I wanted to create
something that was fresh
um but put the series to bed right we
never had a proper ending to the series
so that's what the musical is it's the
yeah we've actually I actually want to
call it Father Ted the final episode and
um and so you know but it wasn't just
that for me this is my pension this was
this was like the payoff like we don't
get I don't get royalties for for Father
Ted
um I have got royalty since the third
time it was it was it was uh repeated or
third or fourth
so
this was a way I had of of getting a
kind of a nest egg to take me into my
old age
um
and I was very proud of it
so
I'm not doing anything until that's made
you know it's too good not to uh it's
too good not to let kind of die in a
Vine well let's hope you can have it
made and uh whether it's whatever
production company you end up doing it I
look forward to uh seeing seeing it on
stage and um uh I've so I want to ask
you about Twitter Eve Elon Musk
follows through on his Twitter amnesty
and lets you back on
will how will you behave will what have
you learned from being away for two
years I you know we were talking off off
uh camera about
um all of us as a the world now addicted
to our phones has there been any
blessing for you that being off Twitter
is is how do you feel about the
possibility by the time this episode is
released you could very well be on
Twitter what what does that mean to you
funnily enough the activism
really got a boost when I was kicked off
Twitter I went out to sub stack and
since since I've been kicked off I've
interviewed
uh you know possibly hundreds of of
people who've been involved in this
fight and I think it now stands as a
record of these years that I'm very very
proud of also the sub stack has been uh
pretty influential and pretty pretty um
it's it's doing very well and uh I'm not
sure I would have had the energy to
compose you know proper pieces of prose
if I'd been on Twitter so it's turned me
into a better writer I think faster
writer and a more confident one so I
think I think eventually yeah I think
eventually when I get back on Twitter I
guess the only thing I would ever change
is I'd have more of a
you do you do have a lot of power you
forget how much power you have when you
when you when you when you tweet things
so you got to be the only people I I now
want to put on blast as it were which is
the phrase meaning you
you show other people what people are up
to are these people who bully women
they're still the ones that I feel
should be exposed should be shamed and
and should be uh you know uh should be
fearing my my arrival back on online you
know like again I suppose yeah ashamed
maybe not shamed but like you know I do
think as I say the worst thing you can
do is Bully a woman I think that that is
really the lowest thing you can do and
um
well you know maybe you shouldn't be
shamed but you should certainly feel
shame I mean there's certainly shame
when it comes to the more extreme end of
things and and uh you know when it's
trans women in prisons like Demi minor
in New Jersey raping and impregnating uh
other women and I think it was earlier
this week that the BBC reported on a
trans woman who had sexually abused uh
13 or 14 year old girl because that's a
man uh abusing uh or raping a girl let's
oh you hear about that so so those
people that that side of things that
there was a serious issue and and here's
the thing I always argued as well those
people aren't trans
like you know I have I've I've several
transsexual friends right they have
nothing in common with these people and
yes
like JK Rowling got into trouble for
misgendering a a man who raped and
killed a 13 year old girl
you know where was that uh it was just a
few days ago it's like he's got [ __ ]
scorpion tattoo on his face wow and and
these and these criminals are just
playing people for fools and these
middle class morons are going along with
it yeah you know so so you know I I
don't want to shame anyone but I
certainly want to hold up a mirror to
what they're doing yeah and to show them
this is what you support this is who you
this is who you've become yeah well you
showed me that the lesbian dating app is
it called her yeah which you went on
self ideaing as a woman with a rather
amusing photograph I should say and but
you showed me the other uh men self
ideating as women who are on the app
yeah and there's not some of them aren't
even attempting to look like women not
at all and they're just creeps they're
just creeps and and not just that but if
a if a lesbian complains that these
obvious men are on their app the lesbian
will be thrown off hmm so for people
like gray Norton to to know all this and
to you know uh not condemn it I I don't
know how you can sleep at night well you
work with Graham Norton on Father Ted
and Father Ted I think was his not his
starting point but certainly was a big
boost in his early career how do you
feel about him saying that cancer
culture doesn't exist and it's actually
accountability culture well he like what
am I being held accountable for what
have I done except defend women's rights
uh tried to stop people from trolling
lesbians on their own apps you know
objected to the medicalization and the
experimentation on children what have I
done why am I being held accountable you
know and and the reason is the same
reason as JK Rowling no reason there's
no reason I just refused to accept a
completely incoherent ideology you know
well Graham where does it end for you do
you what is is there something that you
because this could be an eternal battle
this could be the there's always new
things coming up what did you feel like
you live you've achieved what you need
to achieve in this in this uh fight I
think mermaids closing will be a will be
a huge Vindication as you say
um
but in general I don't think this is a
fight we should ever stop because
because really what we're doing is
Manning the barricades against whatever
weirdness the internet throws at us next
you know this this was like if I always
think that if the satanic Panic which
was uh which was contained to a few
states in the in the in the in the
American Midwest if the internet had
existed at that time who knows what
damage the satanic Panic might have done
this ideology is a good example of what
happens when uh when a a crazy idea
escapes a few crazy Bubbles and takes
over the world and we really need to be
on on our guard now now that we we're
living with the internet It's too
convenient for us to get rid of it so we
have to be on our guard against these
kinds of threats so I'm hoping that that
all the trauma we've been through me and
all the women I support who've lost
livelihoods and relationships and
friendships and family members I'm
hoping in the end that it will act as a
a lesson for the future you know know
because we can't let it happen again we
can't let it happen to such an extent
that the children are hurt you know yeah
well on that note Graeme Linehan is my
it's been my pleasure to speak with you
and and an honor and I really think
you're incredibly Brave man oh sure I I
I the what you have to endure uh to
defend women has been absolutely uh
appalling and uh I wish you all the best
moving forward and thank you so much for
speaking thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]